[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando tenía 78 años mis papás me
subieron al carro yo sabía lo que
significaba ellos se cedieron el carro y
empezamos a avanzar por una carretera yo
sabía que significaba que me iban a
llevar al pueblo de mi abuela y el
pueblo de mi abuela está perdida en
medio de las montañas ahí en una ciudad
de la paz mientras íbamos yo me ponía
más triste mientras por la ventana veía
ese camino serpenteante casi infinito
que parecía hecho por más serpiente
mientras avanzábamos yo me pone un
poquito más y más triste cuando llegamos
al pueblo de mi abuela mi abuela estaba
en la puerta como siempre ahí sentada
como esperando al poco rato mis papás me
bajaron se pusieron a hablar con ella yo
me ponía más y más y más y más triste de
repente mi papá se subieron al carro y
se fueron claro jobs a mil 78 años tiene
que quedarme con ella ayudar con las
labores del campo
cuando veía que el minibús se iba
alejando alejando alejando yo me ponía
más y más triste ya estaba a punto de
llorar cuando siento por atrás que
alguien se va acercando llega mi abuela
mi abuela se va acercando y de repente
se acerque me abraza y me abraza y me
abraza y me abraza y me abraza y acerca
su rostro al mío y puedo sentir sus
arrugas en el sudor que tenía porque en
ese lugar hacía mucho pero mucho calor
entonces siento sus arrugas el sudor y
se está frotando contra mí y yo le digo
abuela porque me estás abrazando y la
abuela
la abuela me mira y me dice hijito es
para alejar el frío yo cuál frío abuela
son 30 grados de calor estás loca abuela
y la abuela la abuela sonríe y me sigue
abrazando en la noche cuando yo estoy en
la cama que me ven asignado y estoy ahí
de charito cuando de repente tengo esa
tristeza que nos inundó cuando uno está
solo y tengo ganas de llorar y mi abuela
que tal vez sabía esas cosas se baja de
la cama se meta la mía me abraza otra
vez me abraza me abraza me abraza siento
sus arrugas y el sudor otra vez y me
dice hijito estás bien yo no abuela no
porque me estás abrazando y jito visitas
el frío abuela está haciendo 30 grados
de calor cual frío estás loca vuela
estás loca y realmente cada vez que me
sentía triste se acercaba me abrazaba y
me decía que era para dejar el frío
realmente yo creí que mi abuela estaba
muy loca
pero así muchos años atrás mi abuela
selección y en el entierro yo veía a
newell y le daba el último adiós
me podría pensar en tantas cosas que me
había dicho el récord de esto que les
estoy contando y entonces entendí
entendí que mi abuela me abrazaba con
ese cariño con esa fuerza a pesar de
tanto calor y lo hacía lo hacía para
alejar el frío y el frío del corazón
bueno soy un narrador de cuentos soy
cuentacuentos después venía a hablarles
justamente de cuentos de historias desde
el momento que abrimos los ojos
somos el protagonista principal de una
historia una historia que vamos viviendo
y transformamos con cada acción que
tomamos pero al mismo tiempo somos el
narrador y la narradora que cuenta esta
historia al mundo que nos rodea entonces
la pregunta va cuando contamos esta
historia que palabras usamos para
transmitir nuestra historia somos
capaces de identificar aquello mágico y
especial que vivimos día tras día y que
nos transforma
y pues estas preguntas nacen de dos
únicas preguntas la primera quien soy y
la segunda que sabe el mundo de mí y
aunque contestar a estas preguntas es lo
más complicado que hay yo tengo que
darles un secreto de todos los
cuentacuentos del mundo bueno pues este
secreto al momento de contar una
historia
hace algún tiempo tengo una de las
experiencias más lindas en mi vida de
cuentacuentos estaba saliendo de una
universidad con la mochila al hombro
había tener una función bellísima y está
feliz y contento caminando cuando siento
que algo me toca el hombro me giró y era
una chica como de este tamaño
si me acerqué me dice si le podía contar
otro cuento yo digo claro porque yo como
principio del narrador tengo la misión
de contarle cuentos a quien sea
cualquier persona que me lo pida y le
digo listo nos vamos a un cafecito nos
sentamos y en eso antes de empezar se me
ocurre algo le digo mira hagamos un
trato yo te cuento una historia si al
terminar tú me cuentas otra ella de
forma tímida acepta entonces yo le
cuento lo que les acabo de contar cuando
terminó le digo bueno este turno ella me
mira junto a los hombros para adentro me
está mirando y de forma muy tímida me
dice es que yo no tengo nada que contar
no me pasa nada interesante les suena
ya como cuenta contra la migra y le digo
pues voy a recurrir al viejo truco de
todos los cuentacuentos del mundo
cuéntame la historia de tu primer amor
ella ya me empieza a contar una historia
mientras me va contando yo la voy
escuchando y le voy preguntando ciertos
detalles que a veces se nos escapan
cuando termina yo le digo bueno quieres
que te cuente otra historia ella me dice
que sí entonces empieza a contar la
historia que me había contado ella hace
dos minutos si empiezas con tareas se
las sigo contando sin decir contando y
abriendo los ojos y se ve emocionando y
se va emocionando y cuando termina la
historia una historia que termina con un
beso o una canción y una traición
ella se queda quieta disfruta
luego me mira y me dice de verdad me
pasó todo esto a mí yo digo si te pasa
todo esto a ti y entonces hace una pausa
y es una pregunta que nunca voy a
olvidar y como es que yo no puedo
contarle así
saben nos dicen cuéntame algo
normalmente decimos que no tenemos nada
que contar que lo mágico y especial y
único le está pasando a alguien al otro
lado del mundo que le está pasando al
otro lado de la tele pero eso no es
cierto nos pagan cada cosa mágica
especial única poética cada cosa pero lo
que pasa es que realmente al momento de
contarla no tenemos el valor o no
aceptamos realmente eso que nos está
pasando y estamos peleados con nuestra
propia historia entonces yo les propongo
que tal si un día nos invitamos al cine
otro día os invitamos a comer un día nos
invitamos un café nos sentamos con
nosotros y empezamos a conversar
detengámonos un segundo para ver si
realmente cada cosa que hemos vivido es
linda es hermosa y yo les aseguro que lo
es
porque dicen
que aquello que no se cuenta a través
del mundo de las palabras cae
irremediablemente en el mundo del olvido
y el olvido no devuelve nada no sabría
cómo pero las palabras a ellas si les
gusta llevar a las personas por el viaje
de alguien llevarlas y encaminarlas por
un camino a veces lindo a veces tétrico
pero es un viaje al final de cuentas
hay que contar contar a aquellos que
estamos viviendo porque cuando lo
decimos en voz alta damos el primer paso
para que una idea que tenemos aquí en la
cabeza se convierta en realidad porque
cuando lo decimos en voz alta es un
recordatorio constante para aquellos que
nos escuchan y nos digan tú dijiste que
vas a viajar yo pues digo bueno voy a
viajar otro dijiste que vas a ser
presidente tal cosa bueno voy a hacerlo
dijiste que vaya a acabar la carrera
entonces lo voy a hacer porque es un
recordatorio constante para nosotros
mismos porque lo que se dice en voz alta
existe y si no me creen solo pónganse a
pensar desde este ejemplo no imagínense
que una chica hermosísima bellísima
linda yo que le estoy mirando no y
pienso que chica más linda que chica más
hermosa creo que la vamos ser creo que
la quiero y me empieza enamorar enamorar
enamorar enamora y la sigo viendo la
sigo viendo no le digo nadie la sigo
viendo y ella de repente se va
claro no pasa nada si solamente lo que
solamente lo pienso entonces tengo que
acercarme a ella y decirle hola cómo
estás sabes que creo que te amo
claro
ahora que me acepte ella o que no es
otra cosa
saben soy cuentacuentos soy narrador de
historias y soy eso porque lo elegí la
historia de la literatura de la
tradición oral muchas de las que escribo
de las que veo de las que vivo pero
saben también que yo soy narrador oral
se cuenta cuentos porque eso es lo mejor
que sabe hacer el ser humano desde el
principio de los tiempos intenta narrar
una historia la narra con número la
narra con formas con música con figuras
con el cuerpo con la voz con las
palabras la narra y es cierto aunque
ustedes lo hayan olvidado ustedes
también son narradores son cuentacuentos
y andan por el mundo contando su propia
historia
y creo que es tiempo de que cada uno se
sienta y empieza a narrar quiénes son
para ese momento el show les estaba
ocultando yo seguí en el café con la
chica él andaba viendo y ella me voy a
preguntar
disculpa porque no puedo contar esta
historia así yo la miré y no tenía una
respuesta así que la mire
y me deje fluir
más sintiendo que pensando le dije lo
que pasa es que cuando tengo la
contraste yo me emocioné y cuando te las
conté también me emocioné
y aquí es donde va el secreto
todos los cuentacuentos del mundo si
ustedes conocen alguno y le van a
preguntar cual que vean que es cierto
todos cuentacuentos del mundo saben que
hay diferentes técnicas para contar una
historia no así que movimiento corporal
que el ritmo de la voz que la
dramaturgia de la historia hay tantas
cosas pero lo que todos los
cuentacuentos del mundo tienen por
principio y regla es que la historia que
vas a contar primero que nada te tiene
que gustar porque cuando te guste
las palabras no se atoran en tu mente
sino que tú serás simplemente un lugar
donde las palabras fluyan y seguirán
fluyendo y seguirán fluyendo y
conectarán con el que te está escuchando
y cuando la otra persona se conecte con
esa idea se conecte con tus palabras y
tu sinceridad algo empezará a cambiar tu
mismo empezarás a cambiar y la persona
que está escuchando también empezará a
cambiar
porque cuentan los que cuentos cuentan
que aquellas personas que se atreven a
contar cambian el mundo con sólo
nombrarlo
[Aplausos]
[Música]